[Applaudissements]
le conseil de classe de ceux du jour
rachid arhab qui va se mettre en place
et rachid arhab
il est là depuis la rentrée dans tpm
paix c'est une de nos nouvelles recrues
regardez rachid arhab dans tpm puisque
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
big mac mon carnet plein de bonnes et de
mauvaises notes sur l'actualité des
médias non il a flambé et koné c'est
vrai on a des bon dos pas beaucoup de
bonnes notes et m'énerve c'est juste un
petit avertissement et une enfant avec
des pincettes ça c'est pas dépasser des
guillemets d'accord vraiment là on
mélange tout droit de visite rappelé à
quatre feuilles sa part alors là ça très
drôle si vous voulez mon avis mais bon
voilà alors le plus chaud ça va très
bien elle a été en met un temps comme ça
duplex à bien les mecs là bas on soit
consenti une demi-heure quand vous êtes
arrivé je vais y croire pendant trente
ans on voit que vous allez
rachid arhab leur descente de 2h eddahab
et non mais faut dire stop
toc bon allez rentrer à xinhua
utilisez sextoys si rachid arhab
mais ce match dérivés cotés enfin il a
appuyé sur le bouton je m'emballe m j'ai
reçu un sms du csh peut le lire si tu te
rend tout de suite il ne te sera fait au
calme à la télévision avait été inventé
par des gens qui n'avaient rien à dire
et qu'il voulait que ça se sache vous
avez une soirée et vous vous êtes mis
une note vous même un meilleur et vous
nous mais dirait votre note dans un
instant la note vous pensez avoir lors
de ce premier trimestre
c'est le premier premier trimestre de
rachid arhab parmi nous alors les notes
eh bien on va les avoir tout de suite
maxime guény déjà les points forts et
les points faibles de rachid arhab et
après votre note points positifs
rachid tuées l'avaient cru surprise de
cette saison tu restes toi même et tu
agressés
tu as réussi à t'intégrer parmi la bande
de joyeux lurons donc bravo pour ça tu
ne te demande pas tu es souvent parfois
à contresens des idées de cyril et d'une
partie de la bande
ça il faut le faire j'appelle ce site
aux côtés posé des cas les observateurs
et parfois un peu maître d'école
parmi les points négatifs je suis
convaincu que tu peux te lâcher beaucoup
plus c'est pas parce que tu mets une
période pendant trois minutes dans une
séquence dédiée que ça va te
décribiliser non au contraire
crédibiliser décribiliser l'enlève dinan
l'aide des syllabes le gars il parle
comme un châtelain et pack français -
bien que wam
enfin rachid le temps n'était prise de
parole c'est le temps d'acheter de 20
heures c'est fini le 20 heures de france
2 faut le savoir
entre le moment où tu commencé au moment
où tu termines on a le temps de manger
notre soupe donc les interventions sont
trop longues
elle nous ferait presque regretter celle
d'isabelle j'attends j'attends avec coop
alors mes notes et appréciations
générales
tu as commencé l'année en douceur mais
c'est satisfaisant continue ainsi c'est
encourageant et je te donne un set
jouant pas mal du tout aller jean-luc
alors rachid dans les bois positif ta
meilleure émission depuis début d'année
c'était pilote malheureusement la patte
des fusées sinon dans ce qui est bien ce
site apporte un autre regard
tu as les gens s'en rendent pas compte
mais est un regard très très second
degré très british ce qui fait que quand
tu fais des vannes je pense que les gens
ne les capte pas mais capte pas donc ça
c'est un vrai souci
et puis franchement tu nous angoisse
avec les notes là tu vois ça a commencé
ton conseil de classe si tu prends des
notes on a l'impression que tu es un
huissier et que tu aimerais tu vas nous
faire payer tout ça un moment donc c'est
l'inspecteur un petit peu d'écoles
c'était parce qu'on s'est passé des
chroniqueurs comme dirait vianney tu es
là n'étaient pas là donc je sais pas
donc pour tout ça je te mets 4 ah oui
quand même
oui s'il était dur mais il met quatre
îles mais 4,6 aussi sa note il mettra
encore moins quand tu connais trés bonne
note
d'accord je sais ce que je vous disais
géraldine achi d'abord tué sapé comme
jamais entre derrick et navarro et moi
j'aime bien ce côté
[Applaudissements]
impressionné dans une friperie bord
deuxième point fort ton rire taiseux ça
nous change des rires gras et bruyant de
jean michel maire ensuite je trouve que
tu es là bas quand c'est pour vous n'a
rien fait tuer la balance tu l équilibre
qui est la sagesse tu prends de la
hauteur tu as l'expérience donc ça c'est
je trouve que c'est très très important
oui en méchant et enfin peut-être petit
point faible
peut-être même gros point faible ce sont
tes regards des regards sur cyril
théreau garçons parfois anxiogène et
cyril il déteste la contrainte
il déteste les règles c'est un électron
libre apparemment tiré une bataille
gueule ça me fait parfois un petit peu
peur et parfois dupuis rétropédale et
cyril est perdu quand ils rétropédale
donc tu as un petit côté peut-être race
rachid arhab d'accord voilà et pour ça
je donne mes encouragements et je te
mets un très beau c'est rapide je pense
que de tous les chroniqueurs tuer celui
qui est là mon avis la vraie est la plus
grande expérience des médias celui qui
connaît à peu près tout mais de
l'intérieur
donc ça c'est à ça change de beaucoup
d'entre nous et surtout de boxing et
nick
donc ça c'est rien ça c'est pour hier et
donc et en même temps quand tu exposes
quelque chose c'est toujours clair on
comprend évidemment ce que tu racontes
ce qui nous change aussi beaucoup de
jean-michel chacun d'entre eux vraiment
c'est souvent c'est toujours précis ce
jour intéressant et l'info est toujours
au bon endroit au bon moment pour ça
évidemment c'est remarquable et
franchement ça nous change de brûler
entre nous les points les points
négatifs et ça c'est vrai que ça me ça
me dérange parce que je trouve que dans
cette bande
eh bien je suis sérieux de mieux il
faudrait intégrer plus bas je sais que
c'est compliqué d'avoir du recul un peu
d'autodérision alors c'est vrai que
c'est lui faudrait des nouilles dans le
slip mais non
mais c'est vrai que parfois on se bat
depuis pour la halle à ses côtés de
classe normalement il ya la tradition
c'est qu'on soit en tenue d'écolier et
tu ne fais pas donc c'est la tradition
elle a commencé hier on avait des jupons
[Rires]
je me suis habillé en lycéens j'ai mis
exactement le genre de chose que tu
étais au lycée serait beaucoup plus
réducteur quand tu es au lycée de seth
gueko donc c'est vrai que moi j'aimerai
te voir plus dans la bande plus rigoler
avec nos plus ça va plus d'auto dérision
plus de décalages et c'est un contexte
de deuil et en même temps je me connais
vraiment franchement fait un coup ouais
c'était bien celle là alors la note
pour toutes ces raisons je mets un très
beau un très beau 5
on va passer avoue qu'il dit tu as du
métier tu sais de quoi tu parles mon
grand père m'avait prévenu pour moi tu
es le papa gentil de l'émission voilà je
t'aime beaucoup
est ce que je peux te reprocher c'est
que de ton temps tu fais un peu tombé
l'émission l'énergie de l'émission quand
tu interviens un peu trop sérieusement
faut aussi d'ailleurs
avant les dogues sa voix à la fée 2,13
sarah moon a aussi j'étais stressé
pendant des années alesi qui dit nous
donc en gros tu es comme une chanson
disney on t'adore entretien mais par
contre des fois ça peut être un peu
fatigant mais pas mal comment vous
l'avez vigan oui ils veulent à pécho 7
sur 10 7 sur 17 h et je vais commencer
par vos points forts
ouais ou plutôt votre pro forme c'est
l'intelligence est ici c'est une denrée
très rare mais le problème c'est que ça
se retourne contre vous comme un
boomerang à vous ne l'utilisez pas vous
ne regardez pas les émissions et vous
n'en parlez pas fait comme jean michel
lui les voit pas mais il en parle quand
même je ne sais pas ce que vous faisiez
au csa mais ici c'est à menacer tu
passeras mec donc vous vous mettez à
bosser finalement la seule la seule
chose dont vous parlez bien rachid c'est
vous je me souviens de votre tirade
hallucinante oui j'ai été en voyage à
l'étranger
on m'a parlé de mes interventions dans
touche pas à mon poste mais mon pote sur
l'échelle du boulard qui va de 0 à 2
leur monter tout en haut
[Applaudissements]
rachid un bon conseil arrête le mytho
you descend sur terre tu te calmes et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que je te lâcherai
pas mon pote jamais c'est pour ça que
avec générosité et toute mon âme je te
mets un délicieux 0,1
règlement à gâteau qu'on aura on aura
les doyens après isabelle et jean michel
1 voilà merci papa et maman
ainsi ils vous diront ce qu'ils en
pensent alors rachid le point fort c'est
pas le pas ne pas le moins c'est pour
moi tu es l'une des meilleures recrues
de l'émission cette saison c'est normal
des eaux tous les appels à dominique
rousset qui va revenir dans la rocaille
à cette chasse parce que tu as une
personnalité qu'on n'avait pas encore
autour de la table et parmi les
chroniqueurs tu es complètement à part
dans son rôle de garde-fou médiateur
sage mais un rôle que tu sais parfois
surjouées dont tu sait rire et moi je
lui trouve au contraire parfois de
l'autodérision tu sait rire de toi même
et une petite intervention csa que les
pluies aventure balance des vannes comme
ça c'est pas mal mais ça m'amène à ton
point faible malheureusement c'est que
le côté dark à est encore trop peu
prononcé j'aimerais élèves rachid que
pour le prochain trimestre vous
travaillez un peu plus la rigolade
alors élève rachid et août à mon avis
elle doit faire des trucs sur la tête de
ma mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l hôtel et comme ab élèves rachida lui
serra du rehaussement arraché d'essayer
maîtresse agathe pourquoi radiozero
c'est dur john rapide et ce alors
koh-lanta non il faut il faudrait mettre
un peu plus de coeur à la rigolade
collectif
je suis persuadé que vous avez beaucoup
d'humour dans la vie il faudrait que ça
se ressente un peu plus sur le plateau
et deuxième chose c'est vrai que vos
interventions sont parfois un petit peu
trop lente et il ne faut pas penser
qu'être plus incisif vous rendra moins
pertinents bon alors je vous mets quand
même une très bonne note c'est la note
de cette salle wallon alors élève rachid
vous êtes super pertinents
ça m'excite mois
[Applaudissements]
donc cette semaine maintenant
et évidemment vos interventions super et
vous êtes très cultivé alors surtout
votre principal point fort est d'avoir
amadou est quand même cyril hamelin et
là je suis très douée maria oui à mon
avis point que vous êtes toujours au csa
parce que quand même il vous laisse
parler sur la longueur et pendant le
temps où vous vous dites cyril
l'émission n'a pas encore commencé lui
il a déjà engueuler de comics et le
chroniqueur élan navires et trois autres
il s'est mis de l'eau sur la tête et
l'abus du soda il est sorti il est
revenu il a vérifié ces matchs où il a
tout vérifié et pendant ce temps là vous
êtes encore dans votre préambule et il
voulait se dire et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'absolument incroyable
on ne prépare ça ça votre petit ouais ça
veut dire qu'ils voient plus petits sont
là vous avez décroché à quel moment vous
[Rires]
cette jolie petite petite question
n'était pas du court et aidé m'avoir dit
l'année dernière quand je suis rentré
chez nous vous étiez en bas de
l'immeuble et que vous mais bédié alors
que je passais qu'est ce que tu fais
dans cette émission de merde tu n'as pas
honte je réponds tout de suite grâce à
la notion de non je n'ai jamais dit ce
que vous venez de sydney dans la
première version gc ca c'était comme ça
alors je on en a entendu parler d'une
émission de la star icône à savoir soit
proposition qui n'a pas honte de me
mettre en camisole de force avec des
trucs temps ça pourrait se comprendre
excusez moi là où il ya là franchement
moi je vous adore mais on va la refaire
parce que heureusement on peut couper au
montage
adieu la honte à toi là c'est un petit
point le montage si on reprend cette
fois ses points faibles
les pointes à trop long trop lent à bas
trop long trop long quand votre mari
et donc la note soit la dose soit
justement la baisse dans mon mari je te
mets un très beau cette non et ça nous
alors rachid que j'aime beaucoup il a
trois gros point fort alors vous voulez
pas voir un peu avant de démarrer comme
vous voulez prenez un petit coup dès
maintenant
merci merci crash il faut prendre l'eau
à préparer j'avais une petite réserve
trois gros point fort déjà ton petit
cahier qu ils gardent soigneusement
comme dans tes mains tout le pan dans
toutes les émissions
on s'imagine tout le temps qu'a plein
d'infos des scouts afin d information
très intéressante dans ce petit cahier
par curiosité un jour je lui ai ouvert
j'ai trouvé une liste de courses et les
adresses des caisses de retraite du 92
ont visiblement sa part un chef de file
sur des ballons directs au théâtre des
deux ânes sur la vie de ma mère
attention pour l'instant on aura bien
sûr une parodie j'aurais voulu
[Rires]
vous n'avez pas encore je marche dans la
rue tu te rends compte
jean jacques goldman juni métallique qui
déchiraient claudel c'est quoi
ok go sport quelle tristesse le deuxième
point fort la tenue c'est vrai toujours
très propre très bien et bien un mix un
peu entre louis la brocante
l'instit des choristes et jean luc
mélenchon ma soeur a dors et amoureuse
de vous je passe le message
voilà l troisième fois forte et la
diction c'est vrai que vous parlez
contraire un mois très particulier très
bien où parlait lentement sa pré aux
seniors et aux mains avec sanyo arriver
un continuo résultera seigneur comme
isabelle donc ça c'est un autre point
fort votre seul point faible c'est moi
voilà parce que mon petit bonhomme rien
[ __ ] et faire croire qu'on a bossé
savez cet enjeu le phédon j'étais
démasqué dès la première édition
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement pour moi tu es toujours
aussi et ça c'est comme si on s comme
susceptible et a comme h et dont je t'ai
mis de côté quand vous adorez quelqu'un
ça doit alors rachida vends dans la note
des internautes et avant d'avoir ma note
alors je vais vous donner le droit de
répondre évidemment je vous donnais ma
note
moi je vais vous dire mardi rashid oui
moi je suis très très très heureux de
vous avoir engagé je vous jure que c'est
vrai 1
comme je dis j'ai dit hier pour battre
car moi aussi ce qui est important c'est
non seulement ce qu'on fait dans
l'émission mais en dehors
et moi j'adore vos petits messages vous
êtes mignon quand vous êtes là en loge
vous nous servez du papy brossard
il est gentil et en émission je vous le
dit votre point fort c'est qu'à chaque
fois que vous dit quelque chose
mine de rien c'est intéressant le
problème si je vous payez au mot
franchement je perdrais de l'argent
c'est vrai mais rachid achats voix qui
dit quelque chose c'est pertinent mon
rachid j'ai juste un défaut pour toi
faut que tu parles à poil plus fort
parce qu'il ya des gens qui entendent
pas tous ici et isabelle c'est pas tous
les jours facile quand on a voit la
police est pas facile et 2 - chéri
j'aimerais j'aimerais un jour je sais
que c'est pas ton style que tu donnes un
peu plus son avis mais sinon pour le
reste je te trouve parfait et moi je
tenais là j'ai été mis la note de jeter
mis la note de 7 comme benjamin sec
rapide il tout ce que tu as contre les
poux sont rares h
je vais citer un grand penseur qui a dit
je sais qui c'est quand je joue ce week
end à rome tandis que moi je mesure 1 je
me désole quand je me compare je me
console est ce que tu as dit ce que moi
quand je mesure je me désole quand je me
compare je me console
quand je mesure je me disais allez
représenter non qui a dit ça comme ça je
crois que c'est pas super bon lui semble
et de notre dame pour ne pas rentrer
dans dans le jeu mais je crois justement
que l'intérêt de l'émission est de mon
passage dans l'émission c'est que
justement j'ai apporté des choses que
vous n'apportez pas et je pense que
c'est l'intérêt principal pardon et de
même que je ne suis incapable d'apporter
ce que vous apportez mais c'est réglé
c'est là où il me semble qu'il ya un
équilibre que nous recherchons tous les
jours qu'on trouve plus ou moins y
compris dans le rythme si vous le
permettez parce que vous êtes convaincus
que la télévision c'est ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta non mais la division c'est aussi
de temps en temps pour voir ton tantôt
de phrases et demi pour que le
téléspectateur et le temps de comprendre
troisième chose moi je suis très très
intéressé d'être venu dans des tp mp
parce que c'est un public que je ne
connaissais pas forcément et je me suis
beaucoup approché de lui grâce à vous on
vous regarde en faire grâce aux réseaux
sociaux grâce à la raison dont ils
réagissent et qui ne me voit et ce qui
m'a vraiment intéressé c'est de voir que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense souvent
c'est pas un public forcément qui
n'attend que la rigolade que dans le
délire et saignant mais qui au milieu de
tout ça et c'est l' équilibre que vous
essayez de chercher en tout cas c'est ce
que vous dites c'est d'essayer de faire
en sorte que la raison au milieu des
choses où on peut se laisser aller et
c'est des moments où on a envie de
sourire
je vois souvent dans l'ailé les messages
de vos téléspectateurs après une journée
de travail harassant du des envies de et
j'ai envie de penser à rien d'autre
je les comprends très bien et moi à mon
âge et dans ma situation je me dis que
six dans une émission de ce genre là je
peux de temps en temps placé une phrase
et demie intelligente même si elle est
un peu lente ou longue pour vous je
trouve que c'est pas une affaire s'est
passé pas rater alors pour terminer par
des halos rachid et bien moi je te
lâcherai jamais si tu as tu veux rester
avec nous pas c'est une bonne question
ah ben je sais pas j'ai pas réfléchi
encore pas vraiment louise parce que moi
je suis en train de parler budget 2010
instaurant les quatre tirs également mon
ami jean luc lemoine est ce que tu peux
nous dire tu as ta note que tu t'es mis
toi oui moi je le suis mis 5 à moi même
parce qu'il me semble que ça rejoint un
certain nombre de reproches qui ont pu
être faits c'est que j'ai pas encore
réussi à trouver toujours dans le
brouhaha qui a dans l'émission le moment
où on peut se faire entendre parce que
moi ce qui me semble important c'est que
très souvent vous portez les parler les
uns sur les autres et que quand vous la
regardez si vous regardez pas ce que je
regarde les émissions de télévision
gilles et j'en regarde beaucoup y
compris celle ci peut là quand vous là
quand vous regarder à la télévision est
ce qu'on n'a pas le sentiment très
souvent que c'est totalement
incompréhensible pas sans vous parler
les uns sur les autres et qu'on n'entend
pas toujours ils ont elles prévenu a
indiqué l'émission petit telle en 2018
j'ai répondu tout laissait penser
jusqu'à comtois en assignant ça
m'arrange pas pour les assurances rachid
et 10 mois est ce que tu es content
d'être avec nous parce que alors si vous
aujourd'hui on est en direct
moi je suis un homme libre donc à partir
du moment où j'ai choisi d'accepter la
proposition de la friture il
j'assume tout à fait les premières la
première émission je me suis posé la
question effectivement de savoir s'il
fallait que je continue puis très vite
je me suis j'ai répondu oui les
bâtiments oui maintenant il faut jamais
engagé l'avenir l'emploi
je vais te dire la vérité moi je
kifferais que tu reviennes je t'aime
beaucoup trouve excellent dans
l'émission je te demande juste un truc
vraiment frérot je te le demande du fond
du coeur sur la tête de ma mère me
demande pas une augmentation
[Applaudissements]
jd mais soit tête de ma mère tu sais
comment je suis son sim source à ce que
tu peux nous montrer la note que tu t'es
mis un autre cador est une mairie qu'on
rachid lna contre zoug et rentrer la
moyenne 5,4 c'est mieux que bassam a
quand même soit 35,2 dans 55 à 5,2 t'as
vu ses mémoires une gueule non
mais j'ai toujours la mémoire merci les
twittos 6,1
encouragements et combien la vue basse
ham à castres albi hier s'il vous plaît
merci 6,2 5,8 pour l'instant vous êtes
deuxième de la classe rachid et
franchement vous êtes bien au dessus de
la moyenne et le public mais tout ça
c'est bien noté merci ya les quatre tirs
de jean luc lemoine dans un instant mais
pour résumer le camembert comme il hier
pour benjamin castaldi rachid arhab donc
pour tout le monde pour l'été les
terrasses et 8,3 pour cent d'infos c'est
par lentement 27% prétentieux 26 27% et
enfin phone est urgent est en tout cas
vous êtes très important dans l'émission
pour vous je vous aime très fort
franchement c'est vrai c'est partager au
bout de sa période ses remerciements et
finalement je t'aime fortune c'est merci
rachid
[Applaudissements]